Belgium has joined a handful of other
European countries in banning the Muslim
and Jewish methods for slaughtering
animals in you law states that animals
be stunned that before they're
slaughtered so that they're incapable of
feeling any pain Jewish kosher and
Muslim halal rituals whoever required
the animals to be in sound good health
and fully conscious crucially some
European countries do allow exceptions
on religious grounds but the move now in
the Belgium region of Flanders which
could lead to a nationwide ban has
caused outrage among minority
communities that use the practices today
is the last day on which kosher meat and
poultry can be prepared in Belgium for
the Jewish communities of Antwerp and
Brussels this is a sad day for the Jews
of Europe a sad day for religious
freedom in Europe
well opponents of the Muslim and Jewish
traditions though have called the ban
here a humane development they want to
keep living in the Middle Ages and
continuing to slaughter without stunning
the technique didn t get to the zoo spec
then without having to answer to the law
so let's talk to people who have got
strong thoughts on this and very pleased
to say that made the turn T with us
tonight
Belgium joins Sweden Norway Iceland
Denmark and Slovenia are providing no
exceptions for halal and kosher meat to
discuss the possibility of implications
in this with John by the chair of the
Islamic Human Rights Commission Masood
schedge array and belgium-based you on
this live a hi gentlemen thanks your
time today Luke to you first I mean
would you say the religious traditions
and freedoms are under attack in Europe
and where do we draw the line is this
really a concern about animal rights and
their welfare or something deeper maybe
more sinister going on in Europe now
your thoughts first Luke well I don't
beliefs already and I think by the way
that 50% it's a Paul recent poll in
Belgium 50% of Muslims in Belgium
believe that indeed animals could be or
should be stunned before being killed
following the ritual and I don't think
it is against any religion at all if you
listen to an authority of Islam Abubakar
of the great mosque in Paris he says
that to him
the stunning is acceptable if the animal
could come back to its senses after the
stunning witch
the case so abu-bakr accepts the idea of
stunning before killing so I don't see
where the problem is it's a much more
humane same but it's not just kind of
playing with words just just before I go
over to massage surgery what he's saying
that it's okay that the animal is
stunned so it potentially wouldn't feel
the payment then it's okay if it comes
back to its senses so it potentially
could feel the play before it's killed
is that my reading of what you're saying
there yes mr. Abu Bakr says okay it will
be the animal will be stunned and then
killed following so it would feel pain
to him religiously speaking sorry
religiously speaking it means that the
animal could come to its senses if he
were let alive and so it is acceptable
for Muslims that it being killed after
being stunned that's got it
Masood sure Jared sure these Islamic
human rights commission do you concur
with that that line of thinking or or or
not what's what's the problem with
stunning an animal before killing it and
then eating it Oh first of all really I
think to take a quotation from one
individual in Paris as a norm on behalf
of the all the Muslims and all the Jews
in the country it really is outrageous
and I think the fact of the matter is
that evidence shows that there is really
no more harm or discomfort is brought to
an animal being stunned or indeed killed
according to halal or kosher tradition
the reality is when we say stung that
you're talking about electric shock or
in the case of the cows a metal rod
being fired into the brain and really
there is no more humane than the halal
or kosher way this is the sort of all
the evidence points out to that and the
reality is that even if you ban it in
certain parts of the country or indeed
in a country in Europe then it's going
to be imported from the rest of Europe
or outside that area the reality is no
less animals are going to be a slaughter
accorded
to halal or kosher all it means is that
Muslims and Jews are going to be given
the perception that they are not full
citizens and indeed their rights in
their own country and in their own area
it's been on their mind
so much so did you really feel put upon
by this I mean what do you think is
behind this a genuine as I've just asked
Luke just now a genuine concern for
animal rights or is there something
deeper going on in Europe III can see
Luke come straight line in Europe there
is a rise of the new phobia and sort of
fascism in Europe and although some
might be just concerned about the human
animal right but really there is a whole
wave of people who trying to undermine
the right of minority Muslim or the
Jewish community and make him feel
uncomfortable feel make him feel that
they are not really part of that society
as I said there's not going to be even
one less animal being slaughtered
according to those tradition only means
in comfort of exporting it in rather
than actually having that been done in
the locality and really if we want to
stop hardship coming to animals then we
should all become vegetarian and that is
the really only other option the reality
is scientifically it's been proven that
there's no extra hardship is brought to
animals using these different methods
well obviously a lot of people to
security Masood any thoughts on that
Luke Rivera this is a practice that's
been carried out for 1,500 years by
Muslims and Jews why should it not
continue well in Europe I mean in
Belgium for example it's more than 150
years ago that it was decided for humane
reasons to stun the animals before
killing them we simply respect our laws
and in this instance I must say that I
have seen myself oxen and cows being
killed and the animal is in panic before
because the animal is turned very slowly
to have
the head down and then only killed and
won it the throat is slit it takes more
than one minute before it becomes income
unconscious so it is pure cruelty for
3-4 minutes
this is unacceptable frankly if people
could see this whether Muslims or
Christians or whatever they read
understand that the animals suffer
unacceptably that's all yeah animal
rights activist Ducey is excessively
cruel we sued what you can to that we're
coming we're in 2019 no look look the
fact of the matter is that
scientifically is being proven is not
cutting the throats of the animal the
mains arteries on either side are
actually cut the minute you cut those
and it takes seconds in the second that
you do that no blood flows to the brain
so brain cease to function
no pain no no hardship is brought
because the brain cease to function and
this is what is being proven the fact
that people are going just on pure
emotional or xenophobic sort of
consideration and actually looking into
this rather than looking into it
scientifically there's the reason that
we are here yeah we could be here all
night debating the veterinary medical
side of it I suppose there's the
economic side of it Luke as well I mean
looking at the stats here there are half
a million Muslims in Belgium around
30,000 Jews if this new law does go
through it could put kosher businesses
or businesses at risk
and anyway Europe's supposed to be
openness and tolerance and accepting
minorities yeah but tolerance and
acceptance of minorities goes to a
certain point there are laws for example
we don't accept or we don't accept
polygamy we don't accept marriages of
underage girls we don't accept the hijab
in the public space that's our law sorry
so it's not it's not against Muslims
it's not against the Jewish community at
all and again nine Belgians out of ten
support this stunning issue so laws are
made by the majority and we must respect
this
even if it's understand it's a bit
emotional I understand that people want
to eat meat and that they want the
animals to be killed humanely very
quickly first stunning and then the
ritual can be applied of whatever
religion and mr. Abu Bakr that I
mentioned early is the Imam of the
greatest mosque in France
so it's not anybody is it then the
flipside of this of course is that it
could generate little of anger a lot of
hatred in Europe amongst these
minorities towards the rest of people
were living working there do you think
about that guys the fact of the matter
is Vietnamese is going to exclude I mean
I can hear I can hear or my colleague is
keep on saying that our laws I mean the
Jewish community members and the Muslim
community members are Belgium too we
can't have a situation that you have a
dictatorship of majority exposing and
putting pressure on minorities for no
reason as I said scientifically proven
there is no extra hardship is brought on
the homo when it is not ELISA accurately
according to his side that is true that
is true that is much more true than you
highlighting one abu-bakr from france
for as your reason for moving forward
the reality is that also you are not
going to stop your living in a global
European community and indeed those
slaughtering which is not is not going
to be done in Belgium it's going to be
done in France and elsewhere so the
reality is that all you're doing you're
actually excluding your Muslim and
Jewish community from being part of the
Belgium and you are not stopping any
single animal being slaughtered
according to Islamic or Jewish tradition
because they will continue gentlemen
from the Jewish community and the Muslim
community will continue eating halal and
kosher gentlemen we'll leave it there
massage surgery chair of the Islamic
Human Rights Commission belgium-based
generously give a thank you so much for
your time
New Year to you as we head into 2019
thanks for being on Rt
you